one of the biggest mistakes I made early
on when I had any money was I just tried
to invest it and put into the stock
market and I remember like a 2005 put it
in the stock market it's gonna grow it's
like oh it's like taking so long to grow
it's only two thousand dollars where
Jeremy actually made a much smarter call
like I think at the beginning you invest
in your skills and you invest in your
network because that 2500 investment
that Jeremy made now has a mid six
figure or high six-figure business every
year because it came to that event put
it into the stock market sure it would
grow but I think at the beginning you
need to invest in yourself to get the
skills that you need to be able to then
create the network and create value for
other people